black people white people gay straight
lesbian transgender
ex-cons latin asian all of us come
together working
all coming together to add patches to a
quilt
that is as diverse at it as it can be
diversity
at its best tyler perry delivered an
impassioned speech sunday night at the
2020 emmy awards
as he was honored with the governor's
award for his contributions to the
television industry
the 51 year old mogul started off by
thanking the academy and his team
clearly moved by the impact of the award
this is uh amazing i didn't expect to
feel this way
then perry recalled a story about a gift
his grandmother gave him when he left
home at 19
a multi-color quilt that he didn't
really care for
and used as a rag but after learning
more about it he grew to love it
here i was a person who prides myself on
celebrating our heritage
our culture and i didn't even recognize
the value in my grandmother's quilt
i dismissed her work and her story
because it didn't look like
what i thought it should perry also
shared a memory from his childhood
watching his father at home frustrated
for working all week
yet never getting paid a lesson his
mother warned him about
she turned to me and she said don't you
ever stand by door waiting for white
folks to do nothing for you
she couldn't imagine a world where her
son was not waiting by the door for
someone
in her quilt she couldn't imagine me
actually building my own door
and holding that door open for thousands
of people
in in my mother's quilt she couldn't
imagine me owning land that was once a
confederate army base
where confederate soldiers plotted and
planned on how to keep blacks enslaved
perry concluded his touching speech by
acknowledging the value of
every patch in a quilt and reflecting on
the significance of his success
in my grandmother's quilt there were no
patches that represented black people on
television
but in my quilt her grandson is being
celebrated
by the television academy e.t spoke with
perry in august just
hours after learning he'd be receiving
the governor's award
for the governors to to even consider me
for it and
to know that they were watching and
paying attention that was really really
powerful and
i i was blown away by it blown away by
it bringing it full circle
the entertainer shared who inspired him
to always give back
where does that come from that pay it
forward attitude
oh that's the dna of my mother you know
my mother was just such a
kind woman i realize that you know
people uh people
aren't are out there uh struggling
because they want to
you know they're people who just need a
hand up and that little bit of
motivation
can take them a long way i'll never
forget being in the grocery store in
winn-dixie
in atlanta trying to uh pay for some
food and couldn't pay for it the woman
behind me
who who gave them me the money to get
the food that i needed
never knew her again but that little act
of kindness felt made me feel like i
could go on so
that's what those moments are about for
me just making people feel like they can
go on